blink once if you come back to life
blink twice if you if you're dead
forever or stare straight I have been
groomed and trained you feel like The
Manchurian Candidate like you know what
not to say and and that basically is
everything so next question there's been
an amazing press tour how how much how
much will you miss this family cuz this
is the endgame a lot a lot it's it's
been one of those premieres you know
between you and me and the lamppost
sometimes these things well they always
feel like work it's it's a little
overwhelming and you know these
interviews last forever so you're really
ever in a very professional state of
mind but even even linking up with my
buddies at my house tonight my family my
friends and I've been in LA for 20 years
now and this is kind of the this is a
big culmination to a lot of things so
it's it's an emotional night and and I'm
trying to trying to be here for it as
opposed to you know slapping on that
professional mentality and I'm trying to
be trying to be more human and and and
it feels good
[Applause]
[Music]